Film Courage: What are the biggest mistakes beginning
editors make? Lawrence Jordan, Editor: So many. I I think that
you know the big was some of the biggest
mistakes that beginning editors make is
to be fearful to make a cut you know be
fearful to just dive in and start and
start experimenting and and and playing
with the material and looking at ad it
is something that that you can play with
and and have fun with I think a lot of
people are afraid to jump in and make
that cut on another level I think for
myself
maybe you know I I think that it was ego
issues kind of thinking because I had
come from these legendary editors who
you know had such a incredible body of
work that I thought that you know as an
editor you have to like stand by your
cut and you know and maybe not be so
flexible and stuff like that and you
know that's sort of like the antithesis
of what I believe in editor is now I
think that you have to be incredibly
flexible and you know I think the more
flexible you are the more you're going
to be able to get your ideas across so I
think I think that's sort of a a big
mistake and then you know I think that a
lot of us as editors although I don't
really consider myself an introvert I
think a lot of editors are introverted
and maybe younger editors don't
understand the importance of getting out
there and meeting other people and
networking and putting yourself out
there those are a few of kind of I think
the mistakes that people make um even
maybe one more would be like young
editors you know maybe not young editors
but young people starting out maybe
they've come out of film school maybe
they've made a few films on their own
but they're just getting into the
business and they're just sort of like
maybe trying to break in or
their foot in the door and they talk
about like their films and things like
that I think that a lot of people don't
want to hear about that kind of stuff
they they want you to do what you need
to do like go get office supplies and
get the lunch order correct they don't
want to hear about your screenplays at
that time you know there's a time and
place for everything of course but
that's sort of a general thing for
people just sort of breaking into
editing do you think the prior school of
thought was to stand by just as a writer
is going to defend the notes that
they're given and and want to do the
scene their way it was that sort of the
prior school of thought of defend your
cut I want to do it here when he comes
in the door this way and the producer
saying no do it after you know it was
that sort of the yeah I do think that
that is sort of like you know a
throwback from a from an earlier time
you know when the auteur theory may be
sort of you know prevailed stronger and
people were able to kind of or people
you know or we're able to stand by their
artistic vision I think the business has
become much more of a commercial
endeavor for the most part I think that
if you get involved in a film with that
sort of artistic vision these days that
I think you know maybe like the people
who hire you and everything they
everybody's cards are on the table so
it's not but again I you know as editors
we're we're service people we're there
to help the director have his or her
vision you know realized so you know
there's plenty of times where I don't
think that maybe a scene works is good
after doing the directors notes
but it's it's their baby you know and
we're there to help them out I've
learned as I've gotten older that you
get a lot more bees with honey than
vinegar and there's different ways to
present your ideas other than drawing a
line in the sand and you know that's
usually through dialogue or conversation
or example maybe integrating some of the
ideas from you know your instincts into
theirs and maybe showing that to them as
an alternative I think you want a lot of
like little battles that way and and you
know I think that a lot of directors are
also reasonable the good ones that when
you say you know that you know that's
kind of a inelegant cut was the way
Lindsey klingmann used to put it and I
think that's a tasteful way to put it
across you know it's not a bad cut it's
just not pretty I think that you know
good filmmakers are open to that you're
always gonna get people who will you
know just not want to you know hear your
opinion even if you're right and you
know I think that it's like a marriage
you know it's like you're not going to
be able to be married to everyone and
you got to find the right you know set
of people that you're gonna be able to
work with that you get along with that
you have some chemistry with it's a real
sort of you know marriage like
relationship because you're locked in a
room with that director for for months
on end so you better have some chemistry
together you better like each other
are you gonna be miserable
you